Today,
I want to continue talking about a tobacco
because tobacco law is a paradigm for
many other problems that,
uh,
we discussed,
but also,
um,
demonstrates a difficulties
of managing the relationship,
uh,
between,
freedom of choice and,
and,
uh,
freedom of speech as well as a managing
certain kinds of hazards in the
environment.
And I want it to go to a,
refresh your memory about this idea that,
that uh,
this industry evolved with
a clear recognition that,
uh,
the product that they were selling was
not aesthetically appealing on its own.
Uh,
so the idea that you would have to create
a cultural preference for the product
is really intriguing.
It,
uh,
think about a,
if you are a corporate leader and you
were trying to figure out how to invest
your,
your finances to increase your sales,
increase,
your profitability will,
you'd wonder about,
uh,
you know,
what forms of advertising you could use a,
you'd think carefully about the way
that you would characterize hazards as
opposed to product benefits.
And you probably would think very heavily,
very carefully about the way that,
uh,
you would conduct your own research.
And I wanted to reemphasize
a couple of points here.
And one is the,
uh,
the way that the advertising
had been targeted,
particularly to those that,
uh,
were most vulnerable to
adopting a cigarette products,
tobacco products,
uh,
in the early teens,
really between the ages of 12 and 50,
15 years of age.
Uh,
and I also wanted to bring to your
attention a one target of advertising,
but I didn't discuss the other day.
Uh,
which is interesting.
there is an overlap obviously between
the intensity of physical activity among
the young,
uh,
so that,
the youngest are most physically active.
Uh,
and those that participate in sports,
uh,
became figures that promoted tobacco
use in a variety of different media.
Uh,
there was a concentration,
not just a to target
women and ethnic groups,
uh,
but also exceptional athletes in
a variety of different sports.
So claims that they don't get your
wind as an example appeared in popular
mechanics,
uh,
more than half a century ago.
I also did not talk about other
kinds of tobacco products.
And,
uh,
it was curious because I had,
a class,
uh,
several years ago with,
perhaps,
uh,
four or five,
baseball team players.
And I got to understand that a chewing
tobacco is not uncommon at all among boys
baseball players.
Uh,
and there's very little
understanding about,
uh,
the chemical content or the
relative risk of tobacco products,
uh,
cigarettes as opposed to smoking tobacco.
Uh,
so just to provide a,
uh,
a quick back background set of statistics
of the National Cancer Institute,
uh,
has a site that reviews the presence of
28 different carcinogens in smokeless
tobacco.
Uh,
in one dose of,
of smokeless tobacco,
depending upon the size that
you pull out of the camp,
uh,
has three to four times
the nicotine level,
so that those that are chewing tobacco
absorb far more nicotine and it can be
measured in at higher
concentrations in the blood.
Then if you have a cigarette,
and it's now used by almost 8
million people in the United States,
it's also recognized to increase risk of,
of,
uh,
oral cancer,
that,
uh,
can cause bone degeneration and
a different other illnesses,
uh,
of the,
of the nasal pharyngeal cavity.
Uh,
I also did not talk much about specific
advertising targeted to young kids,
uh,
but the idea that the big
league chew chewing gum,
for example,
uh,
would,
allow a kid to think that they
were behaving like a major leaguer,
uh,
by,
chewing bubblegum,
uh,
the way that,
the major leaguers chew
tobacco and also the,
uh,
the sale of cigarettes and candy form,
to children.
These are still marketed,
uh,
in the United States today.
One other fact that I didn't discuss is
the idea of freedom of choice relative
to children growing up
in families that smoked.
Um,
I grew up in a family that smoked,
uh,
and just have vivid memories of
being in the backseat of a car,
uh,
filled with smoke,
or a sitting around the kitchen table.
Uh,
we're,
we're parents smoked and many mid,
perhaps some of you had that
have had that same experience.
Uh,
the estimate today is about 25% of kids
between the ages of three and 11 grew up
with one smoker in the household.
So thinking about,
uh,
the,
the freedom of choice argument
on the part of the industry,
uh,
relative to this population
poses some particular problems.
And I left you the other day talking
about the efforts on the part of the
industry,
uh,
to understand nicotine and a,
the human response to nicotine.
And I want you to think about
this a little bit more carefully.
So,
uh,
this general counsel to Brown
and Williamson back in 1963 so,
uh,
almost a 50 years ago,
claimed.
Well,
we are then in the business of
selling nicotine and addictive drug
beyond nicotine.
By the way,
there are many other hazardous
chemicals in tobacco smoke.
And I'm not going to spend
any more time on this than to,
uh,
let you know that that dozens of compounds
are really a very well recognized and
they are,
are the targets of a variety
of different types of,
of environmental laws.
So,
uh,
these chemicals are,
are,
uh,
tightly restricted under
the safe drinking water act,
the clean air act,
uh,
hazardous air pollutant,
regulations.
So that,
uh,
the idea that they would escape regulatory
attention in a tobacco product where
the dose would be so much higher than
you would get if you were exposed to
outdoor air or too low levels in,
in drinking water.
It's really a very interesting thought.
Now,
David Kessler,
who wrote question of intent,
uh,
when he,
he spoke in this lecture,
uh,
knew of my interest in and,
the research I was then
doing on pesticides and he
pointed me to an expert in
Switzerland who had pulled
together information on pesticides,
used to produce tobacco.
Uh,
so nobody had ever looked at the number
of chemicals that were allowed for use
or what happened to them more
than tobacco itself burned.
Uh,
so it turned out that,
uh,
there are about 101 different
pesticides used on tobacco.
Uh,
and when they are burned,
some concentrations,
uh,
make their way into indoor air.
Uh,
but others transform,
uh,
so that the mixture of known
carcinogens that are not pesticides,
uh,
with,
these pesticide metabolites
or combustion byproducts,
uh,
is really quite a,
quite a remarkable mixture of,
of,
of substances.
Now,
another idea that Kessler had,
uh,
that I've taken up in
a variety of different,
uh,
research projects has been to explore
patents as a way of understanding what a
corporation knew about a product a
and when they knew it and how they're
advertising matched up with
their background knowledge
of benefit as opposed to
risk.
So if you look at,
uh,
some of these patent examples,
that,
uh,
the food and Drug Administration
was able to conduct research on,
uh,
you find that back as early as
the 1960s and through the 70s,
eighties,
in 1990s.
Uh,
the companies we're
conducting intensive research,
uh,
on nicotine content.
Uh,
so take a look at the,
if you take a look at the
first patent description,
I'd increase nicotine content and the
tobacco smoke by use of a nicotine ion
exchange placed in the filter.
What placed in the filter?
I thought filters were supposed
to take out particles or,
or dangerous chemicals.
Uh,
so they're thinking that they might
even add the nicotine to the filter.
Uh,
the second increased nicotine content
and the smoke of a tobacco product by
adding nicotine to carbon
black in the filter,
the next add tobacco extract containing
nicotine to the filter of cigarettes.
The next one create a device to deliver
increased nicotine by applying nicotine
solutions to the filter.
And finally on the sheet method of
producing a rapper for a smoking rod,
uh,
a cigarette which has
a screen printed on it,
uh,
among other things,
they physiologically active
agent such as nicotine.
So thinking about adding ink to the paper,
uh,
thinking about adding,
liquids and vapors to a,
to the filters,
uh,
as well as the example that
I described the other day,
increasing the ammonia content,
uh,
in the,
in the tobacco.
That would free up more nicotine.
So all of an idea to manipulate the dose
that the individual would get per per
cigarette.
Uh,
the,
the list goes on,
uh,
and,
the idea of,
of,
uh,
um,
putting other additives in,
uh,
that,
would make high nicotine content,
uh,
less harsh because nicotine can
can be very irritating to the,
uh,
the throat and the nose,
and also lowering the ratio of particulate
matter of nicotine and smoke using
internal heat sinks and special
nicotine containing absorbance.
Uh,
so the cigarette product itself,
uh,
many have the idea that
it's simply tobacco.
It's not at all.
It's a very interesting combination of
different technologies are all designed
to,
to manipulate the chemical
mixture that the smoker receives.
And as this research was going on,
this slide that I showed
you the other the other day,
uh,
kind of reinforces that this knowledge
was being incorporated in a manner that
allowed them to figure out how to increase
the nicotine content in cigarettes
during the same period.
There was an interesting article that
was published in 1998 in the British
American are,
uh,
by uh,
a researcher in the
Tobacco Control Journal.
Uh,
and it references a memo that
it was quoted in that journal.
Uh,
we are searching explicitly,
uh,
for a socially acceptable addictive
product involving a pattern of repeated
consumption.
A product which is likely to
involve repeated handling.
The essential constituent is most likely
to be nicotine or a direct substitute
for it.
So this is all just to say that,
uh,
as these debates were
going on inside Congress,
uh,
over whether or not nicotine
is an addictive drug.
There is a,
a,
a video that I'll put up on the website
for you that shows all of the de facto
executives in major corporate
executives appearing before Congress.
And,
uh,
we were one congressmen asked them,
Henry Waxman from California,
uh,
gentlemen,
is tobacco,
uh,
or is nicotine addictive,
and each one of them went down the row.
No,
it is not addictive.
Uh,
and this was well after this
research had been published.
Plan.
Well after,
uh,
excuse me.
Well after this memorandum was,
was written,
so that a central debate,
uh,
in the management of the technology has
been over the management of nicotine.
Okay.
Oh,
by the late 1990s,
major medical organizations around the
world had concluded that nicotine is
addictive,
including the US surgeon general,
the World Health Organization,
et Cetera.
So that,
uh,
this eventually prompted Kessler once
he had all of this information derived
from patents,
but also derived from,
from a National Institute of Health,
uh,
independently conducted
research in recognizing that,
uh,
there was much research that had gone
on in these companies that was not
disclosed to the food
and Drug Administration.
They develop their proposal.
This proposal is pretty well laid
out and the question of intent,
uh,
and it included a ban on cartoon graphics,
particularly with an eye to the Joe camel
ad that I showed you a few days ago.
A text is allowed in the,
in the advertising banning
brand names on hats,
tee shirts,
and other products.
Uh,
they targeted event sponsorship,
uh,
requiring corporate,
names,
uh,
but not product names,
eliminating vending machines,
free samples,
and mirror mail order.
Uh,
and eliminating self service in stores
and suspending licenses to sell to those
who,
uh,
did not,
restrict sales to minors.
So the history of this Fda rule
is I think very interesting and,
uh,
will lead to what I think of as,
as one of the more
important success stories,
uh,
in the late 20th century
that a swirl around these,
these,
uh,
environmental health cases,
the FDA rule proposed in August of,
uh,
1996 by President Clinton,
at Kessler's urging,
uh,
was announced by the food
and Drug Administration.
The tobacco industry,
uh,
within a matter of a couple of months,
filed a lawsuit against the FDA
rule arguing that the food and Drug
Administration had no authority over
tobacco products under the food,
drug and cosmetic act.
Uh,
basically that,
uh,
tobacco products were not a drug,
that,
uh,
the cigarettes or the ship cigars,
we're not a drug delivery device.
Uh,
and they also argued that FDA's rules,
uh,
on marketing restrictions
violated the first amendment.
So we had the right to make claims
about our product and to sell it.
Uh,
the major plaintiff's in the,
in the case included a these corporations.
Uh,
and as a side show,
which is a bit interesting,
back in 1997,
John Mccain introduced the
Universal Tobacco Settlement Act.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it passed the revised,
the Senate passed a revised
version of the Mccain Bill,
uh,
that included many,
elements of the FDA rule.
So,
uh,
rather than,
the government agency,
the food and Drug Administration,
just adopting these regulations,
uh,
without going specifically to Congress.
Uh,
the,
uh,
McCain strategy was,
well,
let's try to push this through
Congress and see how far we can get.
But it was defeated in the Senate.
Uh,
just about a year later,
the U S court of Appeals ruled in a
two to one vote that eight FDA had no
authority to regulate
tobacco products in 1999.
Uh,
because it ruled that
the FDA had no authority.
Uh,
the force circuit did not rule on
whether or not FDA is rule mark rules.
Uh,
our marketing restrictions,
uh,
violated the first amendment
and just as background.
But I,
because we haven't spent much time on
the overall structure of the judicial
system,
uh,
there are 94 federal district courts in
the u s there are 10 regional appellate
courts.
And then obviously one supreme court
would want justice and eight associates.
Now,
in part because of recognition of the
medical costs associated with treating
people that tobacco related illnesses,
uh,
attorneys general from more
than 40 states got together and,
uh,
launched a lawsuit and
eventually it was settled.
It was called the master settlement
agreement with the tobacco industry.
And,
uh,
as you may or may not know,
most lawsuits,
uh,
don't make their way to
a trial or to a jury.
Most are settled.
And in this case,
in 1998,
uh,
the attorneys general from 46 states
signed this agreement with four of the
biggest companies,
tobacco companies in the nation,
and it prohibited tobacco advertising,
uh,
that targeted kids younger
than 18 years of age.
So,
you know,
once again,
that isn't kind of an interesting story,
uh,
that a kid's play an important role in
the history of the product regulation.
So what we're a key
elements of this ingredient,
or excuse me,
of this settlement.
Well,
first,
that,
uh,
tobacco companies could
not use cartoon characters.
Uh,
the tobacco companies could not target
a youth and advertising or promotion.
Uh,
tobacco companies could not
sponsor concerts or other events,
uh,
with significant youth audiences
and tobacco brand names,
uh,
cannot be advertised
at stadiums and arenas.
So here you see three
different institutional arenas,
basically,
uh,
considering the same issues.
Uh,
you see,
uh,
the food and Drug Administration
attempting to regulate,
uh,
by,
you know,
uh,
adopting regulations and,
you find,
uh,
the,
attorneys,
attorneys general,
uh,
using litigation as a way
of forcing settlement,
uh,
so that you get the companies themselves
to agree that they're not going to do
these things.
That's a very different approach than,
than having Fda tell them that
they can't do those things.
And then you have the Mccain
initiative in Congress.
So,
you know,
the,
the curious thing about this,
uh,
is that,
you can think about a variety of
different institutional targets for legal
reform.
Uh,
should you target a,
the federal government?
Should you target,
uh,
a federal regulatory agency trying to
get them to adopt new regulations or
should you use the judicial system?
Uh,
so that in this case,
uh,
all three,
institutional venues were being exercised.
I also wanted to pose a,
another,
uh,
problem to you.
And that is that a,
like other types of
environmental problems,
there are certain groups in
society that are at special risk.
And in this case,
uh,
the Americans for
disabilities or the American,
uh,
Americans with disabilities act,
was used to authorize,
uh,
or,
limit,
excuse me,
to eliminate or,
uh,
limit environmental tobacco smoke in
the workplace and requires an employer,
employer make a reasonable
accommodation to the known disabilities,
have an employee who requests
the accommodation so that,
uh,
workers,
use the Americans with disabilities act
effectively to clear up the air within
workplaces.
Uh,
another settlement proved interesting
and occupational question as well.
Uh,
the airline flight attendants were
concerned about their intense exposure to
tobacco smoke.
And you're probably too
young to remember flying,
uh,
when cigarette smoking
was allowed in aircraft.
Uh,
but the distinction between the smoking
and the no smoking zone was simply a row
number.
So a row number 23 a might and,
and a forward might allow smoking
and ruin number 24 and back.
That would not,
uh,
so you could very easily be
sitting next to somebody smoking.
Uh,
and the air inside the cabin,
uh,
is,
is a controlled by the pilot who decides
on what the refresh rate will be.
It's called bleed air that comes off of
the engines and circulates back through
the aircraft so that a,
at high altitudes,
the temperature is really low so that
it means that they have to expend more
fuel the more they recycle or refresh
the quality of the air from the outside,
uh,
to heat it back up to a
comfortable cabin temperature.
So there's a tendency
not to refresh that air.
It's an interesting case at to
couple months ago about an airliner,
uh,
that,
had a fuel leak,
uh,
that,
had seeped into that bleed air and
passengers claimed that they were,
were,
uh,
quite ill once they landed,
including many of the flight attendants.
So let's take a look at the
food and Drug Administration,
a case versus Brown and Williamson.
Uh,
and the Supreme Court
ruling on March of 2000,
uh,
that,
was issued in the five to four decision.
This was interesting because it basically
concluded that a existing law does not
provide FDA with authority over
tobacco or tobacco marketing.
Uh,
they claim that the FDA consistently
stated before 1995 that it lacked
jurisdiction over tobacco.
So the,
and the shift in,
in the administrator of the
food and drug administration,
they were arguing was the only reason
that they were taking this issue on.
And the congress had enacted
several tobacco specific statutes,
uh,
that fully demonstrated that,
they had not intended,
uh,
that these regulations proposed by the
food and Drug Administration be adopted.
Uh,
so congress considered and rejected many
bills that would have given the agency
to have authority.
So the argument,
uh,
that,
the Supreme Court bought a was that,
you know,
this was a matter that should have been
dealt with in Congress specifically.
Uh,
but Congress chose not to deal with it.
So what if you look more carefully at it?
Well,
what if you asked the question,
well,
should it be considered to
be a drug under the food,
Drug and cosmetic act?
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
you might,
uh,
read the statement by an
RJ Reynolds executive.
Uh,
in a sense the tobacco industry may
be thought of as being a specialized,
highly ritualized and stylized segment
of the pharmaceutical industry.
Tobacco products uniquely contain and
deliver nicotine a potent drug with a
variety of physiological effects and say,
case closed.
Now the evidence is clear.
They even believe that,
uh,
they believe themselves
that a tobacco products,
uh,
should be classified or,
or are a type of duct drug.
Well,
the decision as the Supreme
Court interpreted it.
And don't forget that this
is a five to four decision,
which is interesting because the,
the descending opinions or something
that you probably have not read,
but you,
I commend to you the,
uh,
the opinion of Steven Brier,
which I think is perhaps the,
the most,
uh,
cogent,
so that,
uh,
the definition of a drug turned out
to be a dependent and turn about,
uh,
whether or not there was
an identifiable benefit.
So I'm going to quote various provisions
in the act require the agency to
determine that at least
for some consumers,
the products therapeutic benefits
outweigh the risks of illness or serious
injury.
This the FDA cannot do because tobacco,
tobacco products are unsafe for
obtaining any therapeutic benefit.
The inescapable conclusion is that there
is no room for tobacco products within
the FT CAS food,
Drug and Cosmetic Act regulatory scheme.
If they cannot be used safely
for any therapeutic purpose,
uh,
and yet they cannot be banned.
They simply do not fit.
They do not fit the legal scheme
that Congress had intended.
And Sandra Day O'connor
wrote this opinion.
The agency has amply
demonstrated the tobacco use,
particularly among
children and adolescents,
uh,
poses perhaps a single most significant
threat to public health in the United
States.
Yet we believe that Congress has
clearly precluded FDA from asserting
jurisdiction to regulate tobacco products.
Now,
many people heard about this decision
and they assume that the Supreme Court,
uh,
was off their rocker,
that,
uh,
they,
they really,
uh,
we're,
concluding something that,
uh,
was not morally defensible.
Um,
but I think,
you know,
that their job is not to conclude
what is morally appropriate or morally
defensible.
Their job is to determine
whether or not a,
uh,
an agency action in this case,
complied with the intent
and letter of the law.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
it's,
it's important too to recognize that
these are debates about the nature and the
language,
the very specific language and
definitions contained in the statutes,
uh,
that,
provide the authorizing language to the
administrative agencies such as the food
and Drug Administration.
So that,
uh,
continuing with his opinion,
Congress's foreclosed
a ban on such products.
Choosing instead to create a distinct
regulatory scheme focusing on the labeling
and advertising and cigarettes and
smokeless tobacco compared to pesticides
where they created a scheme
that now stands that the agency,
in that case,
the environmental protection agency has
to make a formal finding of reasonable
certainty of no harm.
Not In this case,
not in this case at all.
So that,
uh,
the focus on labeling and advertising
rather than on risk assessment or risk
minimization,
uh,
is a very different approach to managing
a product or a technology and the
marketplace.
So it's express policy is to protect
commerce and the national economy a while
informing consumers about
any adverse health effects.
Now,
one might argue as well.
Well,
how did the tobacco industry
get away with this legal regime?
How were they so successful
in escaping regulation?
It's almost the ideal situation.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
they,
they have the sense of being regulated,
uh,
because of the advertising controls.
Uh,
but they have virtual
freedom to manipulate the
chemical composition of their
products.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
you know,
if I were a tobacco executive,
I would think that legal regime is,
it's pretty good.
And I would,
uh,
definitely defend against any change in
the legal regime that would increase the
authority of the food and Drug
Administration on the part of Congress.
So justice briars descent on,
on FDA's authority is interesting.
So according to the FDA,
only 2.5% of smokers successfully
stopped smoking each year,
even though 70% say they want to quit and
34% actually make an attempt to do so.
The fact that only a handful of those
who try to quit smoking actually succeed
illustrates a certain reality.
The reality that the nicotine
in cigarettes creates a
powerful physiological
addiction flowing from a chemically
induced changes in the brain.
The FDA found that the
makers of cigarettes and 10
these a physical effects,
hence nicotine is a drug.
The cigarette that delivers the nicotine
to the body is a device and the FTC A's
language read in light of its basic
purpose permits the food and Drug
Administration to assert
the disease preventing
jurisdiction that the agency now
claims.
So the issue seemed like it was over,
uh,
until the Obama administration
came into power.
And all of these provisions,
uh,
that had been in the proposed regulations
on the part of the Food and Drug
Administration,
uh,
made their way into bills that were
introduced to the house and the Senate,
uh,
that eventually became the family smoking
prevention and Tobacco Control Act,
uh,
in June of 2009.
So this bill,
uh,
adopted by Congress,
amends the Food Drug and cosmetic act to
grant the food and Drug Administration
Authority to regulate the advertising,
marketing and manufacturing
of tobacco products.
What does it do?
Well,
it restricts tobacco marketing,
marketing and sales to youth and bands,
all outdoor advertising within
a thousand feet of schools.
Uh,
it bands a free giveaways,
uh,
of,
any non tobacco items with a
purchase of a tobacco product,
uh,
advance the sponsorship of sporting
events and entertainment events,
uh,
at limits to black and white text
only advertising in publications with
significant teen readership and restricts
vending machines and self service
displays to adult only facilities.
And it continues to require
retailers to verify age,
uh,
for all over the counter sales.
By the way,
I didn't mention a point
that I meant to earlier.
You know,
we talked about preemption before and,
and,
uh,
you know,
under the different statutes
that we've looked at,
uh,
when would the federal government
preempt or prevent states from adopting
different kinds of regulations?
Well,
preemption turns out to be an important
component in this case as well.
Uh,
with respect to the tobacco settlement.
Now,
the tobacco settlement,
uh,
was not,
it was not law that was formed by statute.
Uh,
it was not formed by regulation.
It was formed by agreement between
attorneys general of the states,
uh,
in the,
in the tobacco companies.
Uh,
but the states started to enforce
the provisions of that settlement,
uh,
that brought the questions into court.
And some states such as
Massachusetts in California,
proposed advertising
that a was distinctive,
uh,
and more restrictive outdoor advertising
bans so that no billboards could be
located within a thousand
feet of a school,
uh,
in,
in the state of Massachusetts.
Uh,
similar kinds of legislation in
a variety of different states.
So that the,
the supreme court considered
this a in the 2000 decision,
and it basically reinforced,
uh,
the preemption,
provision,
uh,
that,
was part of a variety
of different statutes.
So that a,
the court found that a
preemption would prevent,
uh,
Massachusetts,
California,
and other states from adopting more
rigorous advertising restrictions.
It's just kind of an interesting point,
uh,
how the attorney's general could,
could draw the settlement issue back
into court and then it would capture the
supreme court's attention.
So that basically you see the language
being moved from the food and Drug
Administration's proposed regulations,
uh,
into statutory language.
Uh,
and this was blessed by Congress.
It provides FDA with authority,
develop regulations that restrict
advertising and promotion,
uh,
to the full extent permitted by
a amendment to the constitution.
And it requires a detailed disclosure
of tobacco product ingredients for the
first time so that tobacco
companies have to disclose not just,
uh,
chemicals used,
for,
uh,
the growing of tobacco.
But the chemicals in,
uh,
in the tobacco plants themselves,
whether or not they're
genetically modified,
uh,
and what kinds of additives they placed,
not just in the tobacco but in
the filter as well as the paper.
It also requires FDA to change,
to require changes to tobacco that,
uh,
would protect public health.
So public health now is a,
a,
uh,
decision making standard that
has to be viewed and treated,
uh,
with every decision that FDA makes.
Oh,
and one critical aspect of,
of this new statute is
that FDA would be allowed,
uh,
is now allowed,
granted the authority to reduce
nicotine content or the band,
uh,
ingredients that it
believes are hazardous.
Uh,
but it's not allowed to
require the reduction of
nicotine to zero or to ban any
particular class of products,
say cigars or chewing,
chewing tobacco as an example.
And also controlled,
gives FDA the authority to,
to,
uh,
control,
reduced harm products.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
those descriptors such as
light or mild or low on labels,
uh,
or an advertising a will now become
subject to the review of the agency.
And you remember that the light products
that I showed you last Tuesday had
higher nicotine content and in them than,
uh,
the,
normal products.
And it requires a larger and more specific
health warnings to cover the top 50%
of the front and rear
panels of the package.
Uh,
and it directs FDA to issue a rule
requiring graphic warnings on labels,
uh,
within a year from now.
So a recall,
the,
uh,
Canadian governments,
tobacco labeling
requirements as an example.
Uh,
curiously,
they also transfer the
costs of all regulation,
uh,
back to the companies so that,
all tobacco related food and
Drug Administration costs,
uh,
now have to be allocated among
the manufacturers of cigarettes,
a cigarette,
tobacco in smokeless tobacco
products sold in the u s,
uh,
based upon their,
they're a different
shares of the marketplace.
So in this interim time between when,
when,
uh,
the food and Drug Administration was
found by the Supreme Court not to have
authority to move forward on tobacco.
And when in 2009,
uh,
the,
the congress adopted the new statute,
uh,
what was happening?
Well,
states became very active in their
own tobacco control programs.
Uh,
and these programs turned out to be
really remarkable social experiments.
Now they turned out to be quite effective.
And in California,
adult smoking drop from 26%,
18%,
uh,
in about an eight year period following
a variety of educational campaigns,
public service announcements,
a school programs,
uh,
so that,
Massachusetts similarly found a
31% decline between 1992 in 1999,
uh,
in Oregon,
tobacco use fell 11%
in Florida in one year.
Teen Smoking,
uh,
had,
had gone down the fastest
that had had since 1980.
The key elements had been
a mass media campaigns,
uh,
smoking bans and restrictions,
particularly in public places and
buildings as well as restaurant,
uh,
price increases.
They found that,
uh,
tobacco adoption rates were
extremely sensitive to tax levels.
So in the states that had
the most elevated taxes,
you had the lowest adoption
rates in states that had the,
the,
uh,
highest,
intensity of bands on a
place based restrictions,
restrictions and buildings.
Uh,
they had the highest rates of quitting a,
so that a price sensitivity
turned out to be,
uh,
a really important
component of the strategy.
Uh,
and they also found that a different
types of physician interventions,
uh,
nicotine patches,
we're more much more effective when
they were combined with these other
educational programs than they had early,
earlier believed.
So basically,
uh,
on another lesson here
is that mass media works.
Uh,
and,
uh,
remember the 1967 fairness
doctrine campaign,
uh,
that,
itself,
uh,
resulted in a significant
decline in smoking,
uh,
in California.
The media campaign reduced sales of
cigarettes by 232 million packs in only a
two year period.
Uh,
and when media spending dropped from
16 million to 6 million of the program
became less effective.
So that education is really
important and it works well.
I want to step back from this case
and I want you to think about,
uh,
how this history,
should be conceived a,
should you be thinking about
this as a success story?
Uh,
should you be thinking
about this as a offering?
Other lessons for other kinds
of environmental problems.
And I've got a number of students that
went to Copenhagen in December and came
back at kind of throwing
their hands up in the air,
not knowing really what happened and
feeling rather disillusion with the
inability of nations to,
uh,
decide to agree on,
on what level of,
uh,
carbon in the atmosphere,
should be allowed,
uh,
or what the rate of,
of uh,
uh,
use of alternative forms
of energy should be.
Uh,
and,
and this history as well as the other
histories that I've showed you that you've
read about through the term.
I think she'd give you some sense
that legal reform is a long road,
uh,
demands,
education that demands a,
a shift in values.
Uh,
and it demands willingness
on the part of those that,
uh,
are the,
the culprit,
so to speak.
The people that are behaving in a way
that adversely affects the environment.
It requires them to earn,
internalize the values that
are embedded in the law,
otherwise it's not going to work.
So I view this as as a,
uh,
one of the,
the,
the greatest,
uh,
examples we've got about how science
had moved out of the tobacco industry,
uh,
into the,
public sector,
uh,
funded by the government.
A very different view of all of what
was a risky and what was not a different
quality of knowledge,
uh,
developed about the nature
of the health risks.
And,
uh,
it eventually led the
public to realize that,
uh,
this was a,
this was a technology,
this was a product,
uh,
that,
demanded greater public attention.
And you can think of the parallels
between nuclear weapons testing.
Think of the parallels between pesticides.
So,
you know,
once again,
I'm not doctor doom and gloom.
I'm sure I'm showing you examples in
history that I think are really remarkable
stories such as the
limited test ban treaty,
uh,
the Food Quality Protection Act,
in,
in this case,
uh,
the statute that was just passed.
Now,
when,
uh,
you discussed this in,
in your sections this week,
uh,
you probably will think about
the different strategies,
uh,
that might be applied to control tobacco.
Uh,
and how the freedom to choose
a should best be limited.
Uh,
so I'm going to do my own little survey.
Here are how many people here think
that the control of advertising is
inappropriate way to control tobacco
products and associated risks?
How many people feel that individuals
want to have the right to choose whether
or not they use tobacco products?
How many people feel that tobacco
products should be banned?
Well,
I'd say maybe a eight to 10% of you
think that tobacco products should be
banned.
There's remarkable
consistency year to year.
I've asked this question for
the past decade in this class.
Uh,
and the number of people
that believe that,
uh,
for example,
DDT or rather a hazardous air pollutants,
uh,
or pesticides should be banned,
is normally far higher,
uh,
than,
than uh,
uh,
it is for tobacco.
So explaining why that is,
is really quite interesting.
And I think that,
uh,
the,
the advertising schemes that I
displayed to you over the past couple of
lectures,
uh,
play some role in having shaped cultural
attitudes and acceptance of this
technology in ways that
really is quite remarkable.
Now I want you to think about
the nature of the politics too.
And then the last few
minutes of the lecture,
uh,
what do you know,
how,
what could you say about the,
uh,
the forms of argument that we've seen
across the different cases that we've
looked at?
How were they consistent
and how are they different?
Well,
first I'd like you to take a look at some
of the key industry arguments that a,
we've seen where the promoter of the,
the,
uh,
the product,
the promoter of the service,
the promoter of the technology,
the promoter of national security.
In the case of,
of,
uh,
the weapons testing or the,
the,
uh,
war games testing and VA case,
they emphasize the benefit of the product
or technology or the social demand for
it as a logic for why it
should be allowed to continue.
Uh,
they argue that evidence is
insufficient to justify regulation.
They play the good scientist,
they develop the science in the house,
uh,
and then present their
interpretations of it,
uh,
to the regulatory body in the industry
or proponent would trivialize claims of
hazards.
Uh,
and compare the hazards
always to natural hazards.
Like we experience a risks
from flying across the country,
uh,
from,
radiation.
Uh,
so the,
uh,
the radionuclides in our milk
are relatively insignificant.
So figure out ways of,
of trivializing risk by using
comparative metrics exposure.
Uh,
you find consistently that a,
across these cases,
that exposure is often averaged among
different populations and it's all
averaged over a,
uh,
time.
It's an average to over space.
It's averaged demographically in
this act of averaging when you have,
uh,
a really,
of the image is really
one of pockets of risk.
The averaging is going to
compress people's perception
of the nature of and the
magnitude of the risk.
So paying attention to the
distribution of risk is,
has been very important to legal
reform in all of these cases.
Uh,
age restrictions.
Also the role of kids,
the concern of society for,
uh,
the,
the very young for the fetus,
for the kids,
for future generations.
Uh,
this is a,
an appeal on the part of consumers,
uh,
that,
is often quite effective
in Leeds industry to,
to still find a ban on,
to fight prohibition.
Uh,
but to accept age restrictions,
to accept labeling,
to accept training requirements
or licensing requirements.
So the strategy if you are the corporate
executive is to well fight those,
but to accept them instead
of taking a product,
a prohibition registration
is a property right.
They will always fight that if you take
away the right to do what they did in
the past,
uh,
that you have to compensate for them
under the fifth amendment of the
Constitution.
So treat your registration,
treat your path of freedom to sell
your freedom to choose a as a property,
right and demand compensation.
And courts have traditionally
responded favorably to these arguments.
Patent Life,
uh,
pushed for the longest
patent life that you can.
Uh,
and you basically want to fight regulation
until the end of your patent life,
uh,
which at that time the
product becomes generic.
It can be picked up by other corporations.
You find this with pesticides,
you find this with drugs.
So that the industry will fight to keep
the product in the marketplace till the
end of that patent life,
which is now a 20 year period.
Uh,
and you often find litigation,
uh,
effective in delaying
prohibitions for 15 to 20 years.
So it's a very effective strategy.
And often if you've invested,
say,
uh,
$100 million is one pesticide that
I've worked on where $100 million was
invested in this chemical,
uh,
to bring it to the
marketplace and to study it.
If you invested that amount of money,
it often takes you to,
uh,
to,
75% of the patent life to start to
get a return on that investment.
So the profitability for new drug,
the profitability for a,
a new expensive technology,
expensive to bring to the marketplace
and often doesn't pay off until that last
five year period.
So that it's a guarantee that
you're going to have a legal fight,
uh,
strategically regulate
rather than band argue that,
uh,
well,
can I use it in a,
can I use the product in
this way but not that way?
Uh,
can I continue to sell the
tobacco and cigarettes?
Uh,
if not cigars?
Can I continue to,
uh,
use a pesticide,
outdoors if you've been an indoors?
So try to maintain market
share any way that you can.
Uh,
and if you can't,
if they decide no,
it's going to be banned,
uh,
then let us export it.
Please let us export it to other nations.
Uh,
substitutes.
Don't compare us among competitors.
Uh,
make sure that you focus exclusively on
our product because we don't want the,
uh,
the,
the risk,
the threat,
the environmental damage from our product
to be thought of in an additive way
with competitor's products.
Uh,
another logic is a comparative risk.
Well,
the risk associated with our product
or our behavior or our technology,
uh,
is really minimal compared to the risk of,
he know not to using the latest
safety technology in a car.
Uh,
trying to,
uh,
launch a suicide prevention program,
a drug control program,
etc. Finally,
a self study,
self monitoring and self reporting.
Let us do the studies and then
provide you with the data.
Don't set up an independent
organization to do that.
So let us report,
uh,
not only on the nature of the danger,
but also on it's a distribution and
a what it's cost of society might be.
Now,
how about the environmental
and consumer groups arguments?
Uh,
how would they respond?
Well,
their response has been pretty consistent.
Let's shift the burden of proof,
uh,
back to the private sector
to demonstrate safety.
Why should the public have the
burden to demonstrate danger?
In all of these cases,
it takes too long and you often
can't demonstrate a danger.
So let's have the,
let's have the expense,
uh,
the time,
and uh,
uh,
the,
the burden to rest on the
private sector a second,
they'll argue that evidence is
insufficient to justify finding safety.
So they will delay for the same reasons
that industry would delay saying that
the evidence is insufficient to
justify increased regulation.
But if this burden of proof is switched,
uh,
then the,
the,
uh,
it's basically providing
a mirror image to,
uh,
the,
form a regulatory regime.
Susceptibility.
Think about how susceptibility
varies in the population.
Again,
all the cases that we've looked at in the,
in the course so far have involved
those that are especially vulnerable,
those that are especially,
uh,
exposed.
Uh,
so look at a exposure patterns
and how they vary by age class.
Look at variability by ethnicity.
Uh,
look at,
uh,
differences in use patterns or
behavior among different ethnic groups,
uh,
perhaps in different seasons,
perhaps in different parts of the country.
So that,
uh,
looking at,
variability and how that plays out and
how goods and bads are distributed is
really important to all the cases.
Uh,
think about mixtures don't
just regulate single,
uh,
products or a single compounds,
but think about regulating
the entire mixture.
Uh,
we've seen that with the respect
to diesel exhaust tobacco.
Another good example,
it's the mixture that's being regulated,
not the individual component
with the exception of nicotine,
uh,
aggregated exposure.
So think about where you might get exposed
to the same kind of a threat from a
variety of different sources,
from air,
from water,
from foods.
Think about the pace of review,
make sure that,
uh,
if you give an agency a burden,
to uh,
know transforma a,
uh,
an industrial sector from,
being risky to being safe,
uh,
what's the pace of review
that you're going to demand?
Uh,
how long are you going to give them?
And remember the idea of a new technology
that would change a vehicle emissions
under the clean air act that requires a
four year period that the industry has
to retool to think about how
they're going to redesign their,
their,
their engines to meet that new standard.
So restricted use and label changes and
ecological restrictions or are often,
uh,
critical arguments of
environmental and consumer use,
consumer,
uh,
protection groups,
and environmental testing,
uh,
make certain that the environmental
testing is independently conducted
and,
uh,
finally are the most exposed.
Also the most susceptible.
Try to figure out how to adjust
the legal regime if you can,
to protect those that are exposed
and those that are most at risk.
And can you do that in a way that would
allow a continued use of the technology?
So it can you protect kids from tobacco,
uh,
in a way that would provide sufficient
respect for the value that we assign to
the freedom to choose.
And finally,
uh,
opposed federal preemption
of state and local,
uh,
local controls.
So,
uh,
environmental groups will commonly oppose,
a preemption because they want
a thousand regulations to bloom.
They want California to have
the opportunity to adopt
more rigorous regulations,
uh,
because California's population
and a consumer market share is so
extraordinarily high as a percentage of
the u s what happens in California is
going to happen in the United States.
And what happens in the United
States is going to happen abroad.
So if you restrict the ability of a
lower level of government to adopt these
regulations,
uh,
then you are not going to
have the innovation in,
in,
uh,
legal reform that you otherwise might.
So I'll leave you with,
uh,
these,
these ideas to think about,
uh,
and how you might conduct
these comparisons and also
how you might take some of
these strategies to the
problems that you care about.
So I'm going to break here.
And,
uh,
I think that we are all
set to give the exams back.
So,
uh,
if you could,
perhaps spread yourselves
out across the front,
so not everybody comes to the same place.
Uh,
that would be terrific.